anfragen sind neuseeland ist mir
aufgefallen dass er die neuseeländische
ministerpräsidentin auf ihr gehalt
versichert sich dafür zwei monate sie
haben am anfang an gefordert von den
fußball-profis dass sie doch auch
verzichten sollen ist das ein thema auch
für sie für ihre kollegen dass auch
dieses zeichen zu geben
also ich bin ganz sicher es wird zeiten
geben ich kann mehr erhöhungen überhaupt
nicht vorstellen
das muss man es mit den parlamentariern
zusammen diskutieren das betrifft
übrigens fast den gesamten
beamtenbereich weil das sind alles
gleich aber ich denke da wird man
insgesamt zumindest dass die politik die
parlamente und die regierungen betrifft
da natürlich ein segen konkret
verzichten
wir verzichten auf vieles wir würden
noch immer vieles machen
ich finde es sollten aber alle gleich
machen ich finde es jetzt in der
fernsehsendung bisschen sozusagen also
das soll müssen wir einen gemeinsamen
runde entscheiden was man tun können
da glaube ich brauche es auch da braucht
es keinen unterschied und
überbietungswettbewerb habe ich mir
alles bereit